this tutorial is about the kraskol
wallis test if you want to know what the
kraskol wallace test is and how it can
be calculated and interpreted you're at
the right place and at the end of this
video i will show you how you can easily
calculate the kruskal-wallis test online
and we get started right now
the kraskolvolus test is a hypothesis
test that is used when you want to test
whether there is a difference between
several independent groups now you may
wander a little bit and say hey if there
are several independent groups i use an
analysis of variance that's right but if
your data are not normally distributed
and the assumptions for the analysis of
variance are not met the kruskal-wallis
test is used the kruskal-wallis test is
the non-parametric counterpart of the
single factor analysis of variance i
will now show you what that means there
is an important difference between the
two tests
the analysis of variance tests
if there is a difference in means
so when we have our groups we calculate
the mean of the groups and check if all
the means are equal
when we look at the cross-cut wallis
test on the other hand we don't check if
the means are equal we check if the rank
sums of all the groups are equal
what does that mean now what is a rank
and what is a rank sum
in the classical volus test we do not
use the actual measured values
but we sort all people by size and then
the person with the smallest value gets
the new value or rank one the person
with the second smallest value gets rank
two
the person with the third smallest value
gets rank three and so on and so forth
until each person has been assigned a
rank
now we have assigned a rank to each
person and then we can simply add up the
ranks from the first group add up the
ranks from the second group and add up
the ranks from the third group in this
case we get a rank sum of 42 for the
first group 70 for the second group and
47 for the third group the big advantage
is that if we do not look at the mean
difference but at the rank sum
the data does not have to be normally
distributed when using the
kruskal-wallis test our data does not
have to satisfy any distributional form
and therefore we also don't need it to
be normally distributed before we
discuss how the kruskal-wallis test is
calculated and don't worry it's really
not complicated we first take a look at
the assumptions
when do we use the kruskal-wallis test
we use the kruskal-wallis test if we
have a nominal or ordinal variable with
more than two values and a matrix
variable
a nominal or ordinal variable with more
than two values is for example the
variable preferred newspaper with the
values washing post new york times usa
today
it could also be frequency of television
viewing with daily several times a week
really never
a matrix variable is for example salary
well-being or weight of people what are
the assumptions now
only several independent random samples
with at least ordinally scaled
characteristics must be available
the variables do not have to satisfy a
distribution curve
so the null hypothesis is the
independent samples all have the same
central tendency and therefore come from
the same population or in other words
there's no difference in the rank sums
and the alternative hypothesis could be
at least one of the independent samples
does not have the same central tendency
as the other samples and therefore comes
from a different population or to say it
in other words again at least one group
differs in rank sums
so the next question is how do we
calculate a kruskal-wallis test it's not
difficult
let's say you have measured the reaction
time of three groups group a group b and
group c
and now you want to know if there's a
difference between the groups in terms
of reaction time let's say you've
written down the measured reaction time
in a table
let's just assume that the data is not
normally distributed and therefore you
have to use the kruskal-wallis test
so then our null hypothesis is that
there is no difference between the
groups
and we're gonna test that right now
first we assign a rank to each person
this is the smallest value so this
person gets rank one this is the second
smallest value so this person gets rank
two
and we do this now for all people
if the groups have no influence on
reaction time the ranks should actually
be distributed purely randomly
in the second step we now calculate the
rank sum and the mean rank sum
for the first group the rank sum is 2
plus 4 plus 7 plus 9 which is equal to
22
and we have 4 people in the group so the
mean rank sum is 22 divided by 4 which
equals 5.5
now we do the same for the second group
here we get a rank sum of 27 and the
mean rank sum of 6.75
and for the third group we get a rank
sum of 29 and the mean rank sum of 7.25
now we can calculate the expected value
of the rank sums the expected value if
there is no difference in the groups
would be that each group would have a
rank sum of 6.5
we've now almost got everything we need
we interview 12 people so the number of
cases is 12. the expected value of the
ranks is 6.5
we've also calculated the mean rank sums
of the individual groups the degrees of
freedom in our case are two and these
are simply given by the number of groups
minus one which makes three minus one
last we need the variance the variance
of ranks is given by n to the power of 2
minus 1 divided by 12.
n is again a number of people so 12 so
we get a variance of 11.92
now we've got everything we need with
these values we can now calculate our
test value h
the test statistic h corresponds to the
g-square value and is given by this
formula
n is the number of cases r bar is the
mean rank sum of the individual groups
and e r
is the expected value of the ranks
sigma squared is the variance of the
ranks in our case the number of cases is
12 we always have four people per group
so we can pull out the ne
5.5 is the mean rank of group a
6.75 is the mean rank of group b and
7.25 is the mean rank of group c
this gives us a rounded h value of 0.5
as we just said this value corresponds
to the g-square value
so now we can easily read the critical
g-square value in the table of critical
g-square values you find this table on
datatab.net
we have two degrees of freedom and if we
assume that we have a significance level
of 0.05
we get a critical g squared value of
5.991
so of course our value is smaller than
the critical g squared value and so
based on our example data the null
hypothesis is retained and now i will
show you how you can easily calculate
the kraskel vollis test online with data
tab
in order to do this you simply visit
datadeb.net
you will find a link in the video
description and then you click on the
statistics calculator and insert your
own data into this table
further you click on this tab and under
this tab you will find many hypothesis
tests and when you select the variables
you want to test data tab will suggest
the appropriate test
after you've copied your data into the
table
you will see the reaction time and group
right here at the bottom
now we simply click on reaction time and
group and datadep automatically
calculates an analysis of variance for
us but we don't want an analysis of
variance we want the non-parametric
tests so we just click here
now datadeb automatically calculates the
kruskal-wallis test
we also get a g-square value of 0.5
the degrees of freedom are 2 and the
calculated p-value is
0.779
and here below you can read the
interpretation in words across calvolist
has shown that there is no significant
difference between the categories p
makes 0.779
therefore with the data used the null
hypothesis is not rejected just try it
out yourself it's very easy i hope you
enjoyed the video and see you next time
you